how's it going everybody it's Warren and
we have some huge news today the x-men
the Fantastic Four the Silver Surfer
Galactus Deadpool and many more are back
home at Marvel and Disney and can be
used in the MCU Disney's acquisition of
Fox is now a done deal
with the announcement that 21st Century
Fox has now completed the distribution
of all it shares in connection with the
Disney acquisition so although this
won't technically be official until
12:02 a.m. tonight Fox has distributed
all the remaining shares to Disney
giving Disney complete ownership of all
of the characters that we know and love
and have been waiting to see in the MCU
and come home to Disney for a long time
now so what does this mean and what is
the future of the MCU look like now well
for one the MCU just got a lot bigger
Disney now has access to some amazing
heroes and villains now plus storylines
we can now see Doctor Doom one of the
greatest Marvel villains in history in
the MCU now we can now see the Phoenix
force in the MCU now there's been rumors
that Marvel wants to do an x-men verse
Avengers movie we can see Galactus and
the Silver Surfer show up now there's
just so much that Marvel can do with
these new characters especially since
that the future of the MCU is supposed
to be going into the cosmos Avengers in
game is supposed to be the ending of the
story arc for the first 11 years of the
MCU and in a recent interview Marvel
Studios President Kevin Feige was asked
what the future looks like in which he
said there will be many more
announcements to come put it this way
it's only the beginning and now it
really is only the beginning because
Disney and Marvel now have access to
every Marvel character the deal has
actually been completed months in
advance and although we're not sure when
we're going to see these characters into
the MCU Kevin Feige has said that he
would like the Fantastic Four to be
first but with a lot of MCU movies right
now in production and pre-production it
is possible that we could see some of
these characters pop up and post-credit
scenes for these movies so huge news
today the x-men the Fantastic Four
Deadpool and all the other characters
that Fox owned are now back home at
Disney and Marvel let me know how
excited you
and let me know which character you're
most excited to see enter the MCU let me
know in the comments down below also a
reminder about my giveaway if you would
like to enter for your chance to win 5
IMAX tickets all you have to do is
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero or
villain as always thank you all so much
for watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]
you